there was something that happened to me
that that we we you briefly mentioned
hearing about before the show is it's
that uh i got denied a
loan for a home and that was shocking to
me because
look i'm not trying to be like a
braggart uh we have a successful company
here
and i wanted to get a uh to get to to
get a small house very it's relatively
small
the bank said no and they sent false
credit information to me
it felt like i was just told you are not
allowed it was three months of run
around constantly asking for new
documents and something
weird happened maybe it was a bad
company that could be the case but we
are seeing this thing with blackrock
these these firms that just get
essentially free money from the fed
and they can outbid any working-class
person to buy up this property
and we're watching them buy a property
like crazy and then turn them into
rental properties
where we're we're going to end up having
the the millennial generation right now
entering their 40s right we're old
people at this point
they have kids the kids are going off to
college in some instances but they're
unable to own property
which means they're they're going to
have less wealth to transfer to the next
generation
they're not going to have something they
control not only that they're going to
be
beholden to student loan debt and to
their landlords
which are going to be big firms yeah and
if you think about
wealth creation and something that
obviously i spent a lot of time talking
about
the way that you create wealth is
through equity and when i say equity i
don't mean
equity in the sort of critical race
theory equity i mean in the financial
terms of equity
having ownership in something so ways
that you create
equity you have equity by building a
business good for you american dream
doing that
you may not sort of have the ability to
do that but you invest in the stock
market and you participate in the equity
increases of
other businesses uh maybe you work for a
private company and you're able to get
stock options so you get to own a piece
of the business that you're working for
you own a house and you get equity
ownership
is wealth creation and so limiting those
opportunities
by government interference in the free
market
leads to less wealth for everyone and
that's the frustrating part for me
um my background we talked about being a
recovering investment banker but
i i'm the first person in my my
immediate family who graduated from
college
my dad was an electrician you know his
parents went through the great
depression and were super poor and grew
up on the west
side of chicago that's where he grew up
and so he you came out of there
and worked really hard and saved up a
bunch of money and then sent me to
school and couldn't afford it so then i
had to pay down my college loans and so
on and so forth
but i've gotten to the point where i am
today which
nobody could believe because of this
american dream because of the system of
capitalism
and i've watched it over the course of
my career
from whether it's interference in the
stock market and you're seeing this in
the the ape community
and the retail investors who are trying
to fight back against you know the the
tilted playing field in stock market
you're seeing this in small business
versus big business
you're seeing us move away from
capitalism
and we've exported it we exported it to
china to their benefits
and we've imported more central planning
to our detriment
and that is affecting the wealth
creation opportunities
because with capitalism the pie grows
and there's an abundance
ability for anybody to participate in
that
it's interesting i mean a lot of people
talk about a communist takeover here in
the united states our cultural marxism
and then we think about the buying up of
all these properties
and how it will result in a generation
not probably not millennials maybe
necessarily gen z but certainly gen
alpha is going to be a generation of
renters what happens
when there's an economic crash and not a
single individual or i should say for
the most part 90
don't own the property and can't pay
their rent and then you get a massive
government intervention to a big firm
saying we're going to bail you out in
exchange for partial ownership and now
the government government becomes one of
the largest stakeholders
in owning all of the buildings that
people live in
it may not be communism but you're
certainly walking very close to the
government owning where you live
well or potentially that you have you
know all these dollars coming in from
china which we've seen happen as well
and you have
people who chinese you know chinese
people not american chinese people but
actual communist
chinese who are buying up properties as
well it's another possible way to
you know infiltrate and take over the
the country
by taking over the wealth creation
opportunities
yeah so i i have some articles i want to
show you real quick this one's from may
28th
forbes realtors will hate me for this
but here's five reasons why you
absolutely shouldn't buy a home right
now here's another one
millennia nearly two-thirds of
millennials have home buyer regrets
new survey says how about this one
millennials who snapped up homes in the
hot real estate market reveal their
biggest regrets
from unexpected costs to high mortgage
payments op
ed home prices are going through the
roof millennials piling the market is
one big driver
can we talk about the government
inflation piece of this as well so this
is really
fascinating uh may report from the
national association of home builders
said that government regulation adds
94 000 to the average
price of a new home built jeez then go
take a look at property taxes and how
much
those continue to increase every year so
just the government
itself is adding more and more cost to
home ownership
and if you go back to the market
dynamics of supply and demand
how many times do people want to build
more housing
and they're not able to because of
zoning laws or nimby or you know
whatever it is
and so we have this constricted supply
of housing as well and so you've got all
these ways that the government
is interfering in the market between the
fed between the government inflation
between the the laws well it's these
media outlets
seem to be trying to discourage people
from owning homes as well right so
already you have it
very difficult for millennials to
compete with massive firms
now they're being persuaded by the media
don't don't buy a house oh they regret
all of it
this is one of the craziest things to me
this um this millennials buy homes and
regret it
i think these millennials i've said it
before if you buy a house
if you save up for a down payment you
can get a what what's
can you do zero down right now i'm not
entirely sure i mean it used to be a big
thing
so i think that they've actually cracked
down quite a bit as as you know
they've actually made it more difficult
in many ways to get homes they're not
sort of doing this this free-for-all
that they did
um but as you know it always ends up
bifurcated where people who you're like
well how did that person get a house get
the house
um and then you know people who have
great credit and whatnot
are finding they have to jump through a
billion dollars yeah yeah for me
it was it was a three months of hoops
and they ultimately said no yeah but
uh i guess what i want to tell
millennials his message is
if you end up being able to buy a house
if you save up you enough you need as
much as you need for the down payment
maybe it's five percent so if it's like
a two
thousand dollar house you might only
need ten grand and not an easy feat for
a lot of people but if you can save up
maybe you have a significant other
if you don't like the house rental
management companies
can run it for you and you are a
homeowner and you're a landlord
it's crazy to me that they're trying to
tell people not to do this
it's it's it's going to create
corporations
companies that own the property and the
people who don't that's the direction
we're heading in
and i'm going to tell you man it's going
to be a dystopian future when people
don't own anything
that's that that's that's the great
reset it's these articles where they're
like home ownership is bad people don't
want it is the most blatant manipulation
i've i've seen in the last two years
from corporate media about what we're
talking about the great reset and it's
sad that
more people don't know that this is
manipulation that this is
yeah that this is marketing and that
it's i mean they could just say
maybe buy a smaller house i mean part of
the issue is right is that we've kind of
gone to this mcmansion
kind of thing if you think about the
square footage of the houses that people
grew up in
back in the day well i'm older than you
but back back in my day when i walked to
school uphill both ways
um you know that the houses were much
smaller
and so we've we've kind of gone into
this place where there's bigger
but there's all different kinds of
options and so maybe it's yeah maybe you
don't need the bigger house but still
buy something get equity get ownership
ownership leads to wealth we want to
encourage
prosperity for everyone we want everyone
to be in the game because if you don't
have
everybody in the game go ahead
i was going to say um the message that
we espouse is empower yourself yes
the message that these firms and the
media says is
disempower yourself become weak give us
the power
you're the victim right exactly go on
the government ubi let the government
take out care of you get like let them
give you twelve thousand dollars a year
because
that's going to make you wealthy it's
not logical that's what gets me is these
these messes this messaging is not
logical to tell people not to buy land
it's not logical
it's it's someone is doing this on
purpose do you ever
you guys remember that viral video where
the guy's like read a book read a book
read a mother
fn book yes and that is one part he's
like buy some land buy some land
right spinning rims yeah buy some land
man but you give that to your kids
when you go go follow on twitter wu tang
financial
oh my gosh yeah wu tang financial
they'll give you all these kinds of like
great
nuggets you kind of meme style but but
the underlying message
absolutely and you know maybe if the
housing
thing isn't for you then go get equity
in businesses build the business oh
except for the fact that when you go do
that
then you're going to get shut down the
government's your number one risk and
it's so interesting
the parallel between what happened with
big and small businesses
with the cares relief and what you're
talking about with the housing market
because what happened
and you know we've seen it in in
previous bailouts all this money goes to
big companies
the cares act was primarily trillions of
dollars to cronies who by the way didn't
have to do anything
to get it they didn't have to apply but
if you were a small business you had to
step up and apply
and the biggest small businesses kanye
west and tom brady
got ppp loans but your pizza shop down
the road didn't
and so you know how you said you had all
that paperwork that you had to fill out
it's the same thing for the small
business you had to jump through the
hoops they made it hard if you had a bad
background check
they said sorry you know we can't give
you the loan because you've got bad debt
they made it as hard as possible for the
people who needed it the most
who again did nothing wrong this was
government mandate
taking their property subverting their
property rights
and they were the ones that had to jump
through the hoops is that because they
just assumed those businesses were going
to go out of business anyway they wanted
them out of business they didn't care
that that
that is just extra people riffraff that
could come onto the government dole
that can go work for amazon they want to
consolidate power this is
central planning versus decentralization
this is crypto
versus the fed this this is what's
happening retail versus the market this
this
is decentralization versus
centralization and then it comes back to
crypto
you know why there's this um move
against it
why many many poor people are convinced
to get away from it why the articles say
china's cracking down dodge this don't
go near it
and it's an escape right that's how it's
been described by a lot of people who
had max kaiser on the show and he said
it gets you out of that system
maybe you can't own property but you can
own crypto and that's something they
can't control and boy do they not like
that
no they don't i mean and that's that's
potentially crypto's biggest risk right
now
is that you have a stock market that's
valued in dollars you have an irs that
takes payment in dollars and you have a
u.s
government with us the central bank's
pseudo attached to it that has a
military
although the military's gone woke so
maybe that's not as big of a risk
anymore
um but you know they don't want to give
up
that power they don't want somebody else
to
have that power and be in the in club
are you can they're gonna do everything
they can to fight it
which is exactly why people are fighting
back against it which i think is great
and i think needs to happen
but that's where this is gonna come down
to and so
that's what we need to be watching so
all of this stuff right the war on small
businesses
the the the telling people to buy houses
and taking with their property what's
the future you see if this trend
continues
so what's going to end up happening is
that you have
you have small businesses you're going
to have economic freedoms taken away
and you're going to have them taken away
and we've seen the seas planted it's
under the guise of capitalism
capitalism isn't working they tell you
we're in
late stage capital capitalism is just
freedom choice and transparency with
property rights so there is no
stages it's just kind of like on a
spectrum over here with free choice
versus forced coercion and control and
so they're going to blame capitalism
they get people riled up and go yeah you
know you're right we should probably
have the government in charge of more
things it's going to kill more
businesses
and you're going to end up with some
form of a
pseudo centrally planned hybrid economy
where maybe
you know amazon and you know 50 other
companies get a do their thing
and everything else is the government
and like you said you owe nothing you
have no wealth creation opportunities
and we have squandered
the biggest opportunity for economic
freedom that has ever
happened in history in the world what
scares me about all this is that
yes there's this idea you will own
nothing and you will be happy
but i don't believe that centralized
economies
or or command control and
authoritarianism actually work it's it's
this utopian pipe dream
some history has proven that they don't
we don't have any example
anywhere in history that it's ever
worked so so yeah you don't just have to
believe it you could just follow the
data
so what happens is you get every what is
it every generation or
multiple generations you get some
crackpot despot saying
i should control everything because i'm
smarter than all them
and then they realize calculating the
economic requirements
of billions of people cannot be done by
a single mind or a committee or a
council
or a small firm it requires
decentralized economics or hey
free enterprise 100 100
i mean this this is and you go back to
basic economics by thomas sowell or
anything else
and and people making free choices are
going to
tell the market what they need and
certainly at any point in time there may
be a slight dislocation
but it gets it gets fixed i mean look at
toilet paper right
what happened in march of 2020 we had a
problem people decided to have a run on
toilet paper i don't know why that was
the like one thing if there's going to
be a pandemic that you're worried about
but people cared about their behinds i
have a bidet
wasn't a big deal to me um but i'm ah
i'm always ahead of the curve
so you know marco rubio goes out and he
writes an op-ed
and like one of the papers like oh well
we really need to be on top of the
supply chain the market figured it out
in a couple months
there was more toilet paper than anybody
wanted and certainly
there are going to be continued
disruptions when the government
intervenes
but if you let the market sort itself
out like it's going to
figure it out over time yes there's
going to be bad actors
there is bad actors in every system or
un system as i like to call capitalism
but
you know you have rules and regulations
in place to take care of those specific
things that infringe on property rights
but there is never going to be a
committee of people
who have your best interest at heart i
mean that's the part that's that's the
worst is people seem to think
that there are these people sitting in
washington who want them to succeed
and that they're going to do what's
right for them over their own best
interest
that is just not human nature that's why
we're representative of
democracy doesn't work because those
people do not represent others they
represent themselves
and it's up to the individual to
represent themselves it's it's we're in
an
ancient system right it's back to milton
friedman you know where are you going to
find these angels to organize the
economy for us
and this is the part where it's like
both frustrating and exciting
because like i look at the people who
like with the former bernie bros and
progressives
and sort of the independents where i sit
and even some of the conservatives
and a lot of us are circling around the
same ideas guys like we have the same
issues we have the same problems we just
haven't quite gotten there on the
solution and so i hope that people
who may not you know who may think the
government is the right answer
takes a look at what the government's
been involved in
how many laws we have how much money
they're spending like what their
outcomes have been and go oh my god
we've got frankenstein we gotta kill the
monster here
and let's look at the other opportunity
is there a way
even if you don't if you think the
government somehow needs to be involved
is there a way to bring
more transparency and more free choice
to everything we do and keep the
government out of the way
one of the challenges is the media you
know we both love it we hate it
but you mentioned more choices if people
don't know something exists
or you know how do they find it how they
buy it and it's something that i think
with steve jobs who said how do they
know they want it if they've you know
never seen it
so you have to you know explore and make
things but
to this point when it came to toilet
paper and the gasoline thing that
happened
just this past month or so with the
shortage in local shortages
it was the media you know the media
started telling people toilet paper was
vanishing so people got up and ran to
the toilet
don't whatever you do don't buy
toilet paper i mean it don't
buy toilet paper i mean do you have
stock in charmin or something
it's i'm short charming it's like the
fire alarm where it's like don't pull
like
all i wanna do is just pull anytime they
tell me not to do something or they tell
you that it's going to be a panic
like that's of course that's what's
going to set people off like this
it's like nobody understands human
nature or perhaps they understand it
very well
and they're manipulating you you're
right human nature is very interesting
because language is not literal
when you say don't get angry what people
are hearing is
calm get down they're literally hearing
get angry get angry the word don't's
there but they're hearing get angry get
angry so it it vibrates a different ang
it makes people get so you want to say
like be happy
be peaceful not don't be angry it's a
double negative it doesn't work in
language
not spoken language calm down calm down
any any woman
you ever tell any woman to calm down
your marriage will end
like they're on the spot like the two
least effective words together
in the human language is calm down i've
noticed if you tell people
you're happy you're listening to me then
they start to listen to you as opposed
to in a fight being like you're not
listening then they stop
then they're like i'm not listening okay
i'm not listening i'm not listening
and so you want to like create you know
positive yeah i mean this is what improv
is based off of
but fun fact me i actually studied with
second city
um and so i've got a little bit of
improv background and so one of the
things they teach you in improv is this
technique called yes and it's like the
you know kind of ground floor
where is when somebody says something
instead of like saying
no and like going direction you say yes
and
and then you go and you use that to
build a bridge to something and so it's
acknowledging
like yeah i hear what you have to say
and like like let's bring this
into the discussion too it's just it's
the same thing but it's communicated in
a way that's more inclusive
and makes people feel like like you're
taking and listening to them which
by the way at the end of the day a lot
of that's what a lot of this is about is
people just want to be heard
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
tim channel irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you